بعد نحو ثلاثه اعوام ونصف حصد فيها فيروس
كورونا كوفي 19 نحو 20 مليون شخص اطلغت
منظمه الصحه العالميه نبا سعيدا اعلن
المدير العام للمنظمه تدرس ادهانو في عقاب
اجتماع لجنه الطوارئ الخاصه بالجائحه ان
كوفي 19 لم يعد يعتبر حاله طوارئ صحيه
عالميه بمعنى ان الفيروس لم يعد يستدعي
ابقاء مستوى التاهو الاقصى المعلن منذ
نهايه عام 2020
حاله الطوارئ صحيه عالميه لكن ذلك لا يعني
ان الفيروس قد انتهى كتهديد الفيروس ما
زال قاتلا ويبقى خطر ظهور متغيرات جديده
تسبب طفرات جديده في الحالات والوفيات
قائما
تشير احصائيات منظمه الصحه العالميه الى
ان عدد الوفيات بسبب كوفي 19
المسجله حديثا انخفض بنسبه 95% منذ يناير
الماضي لكن في المقابل كانت هناك سته عشر
الف حاله وفاه بسبب المرض بين نهايه مارس
ونهايه ابريل الماضيين
في العديد من الدول تلاشى الوباء وتم
تقليل الفحوصات وعمليات المراقبه الصحيه
الى الحد الادنى وهو ما تعتبره منظمه
الصحه سابقا لاوانه وتشدد المنظمه على ان
مرحله الازمه المتعلقه بالجائحه انتهت لكن
المرض نفسه لم ينتهي
اللقاحات التي ظهرت في وقت قياسي في نهايه
عام 2020 تبقى فعاله ضد اشد اشكال المرض
على الرغم من الطفرات العديده للفيروس
الاصلي
اثارت السنوات الماضيه وحسب وصف منظمه
الصحه العالميه فوضى اقتصاديه وعالميه
تجاوزت انعكاساتها السالبه الدول ذات
الاقتصادات القويه وطالت مختلفه دول
الفقيره والتي تعتمد اقتصاداتها اصلا بشكل
او باخر على الاقتصادات الكبيره
ورغم ان النبا سيسعد نظريا مختلف دول
العالم فان مختلف التحذيرات التي ظلت
تصاحب سنوات انتشار المرض والمتعلقه
بالعواقب بعيده المدى التي تتجاوز انتشار
المرض نفسه
تظلماتنا
جائحه كورونا لم تكن ازمه صحيه عالميه
فحسب بل كانت ازمه انسانيه كبرى عمقت
الفجوه بين الاغنياء والفقراء